يبدو ان شتاء اوروبا هذا العام الدافئه
بعض الشيء جاء في صالحها فكان الاوروبيون
يخشون لاشهر من التجمد هذا الشتاء بسبب
ازمه طاقه الناجمه عن الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه ولم يتوقعوا حينها موجه حاره
العلميه تقول انها 5 10 دوله اوروبيه على
الاقل شهدت درجات حراره قياسيه الاسبوع
الماضي وامتدت لمناطق من فرنسا الى
المانيا وبلجيكا وهولندا
فالعاصمه البولنديه وارسو التي تتمتع
بالسجل المناخي يعود تاريخه الى 100 عام
حطم رقم القياسي لدرجه الحراره في يناير
باكثر من خمس درجات مئويه ويعود ذلك بشكل
عام الارتفاع حراره الغلاف الجوي
والمحيطات حول العالم المانيا بدورها
افادت بان لديها ما يكفي من الغاز خلال
موسم الشتاء الحالي دون التعرض لخطر
امدادات الطوارئ وفقا منظم طاقه الكلاوس
مولر وان تركيزه ينصب الان على الشتاء
القادم مؤكدا ايضا ان مخزون الغاز في
المانيا تفوق مستوياته حاجزه 90% اما في
بريطانيا رجح الخبراء من انهم من غير
المتوقع ان تنخفض فواتير الغازي خلال
العامين او الثلاثه اعوام المقبله على
الرغم من انخفاض اسعار الغاز بالجمله الى
مستويات لم تشهدها منذ ما قبل الازمه
الاوكرانيه انخفاض اسعار الغاز بالجمله لم
ينعكس على الفواتير الاستهلاكيه للافراد
حيث يشتري الموردون الكثيره من الغاز
مقدما باسعار قد تكونوا اعلى من العاده
وفقا صحيفه ممر البريطانيه هذا عدا عن
استمرار ارتفاع اسعار الكهرباء في
بريطانيا بثلاث مرات مقارنه بالغاز
الطبيعي ما يجعله حتى الاجهزه الكهربائيه
لتدفئه المنازل وشحن السيارات باهضه الثمن
رشا خياط العربيه